on vous l'a dit et redit vous pouvez
être sûr du beau temps pour les deux
jours qui viennent alors si vous n'avez
pas quitté la région et si vous voulez
vous donner un peu d'exercice en
profitant du soleil
n'oubliez pas qu'il y as en
ile-de-france de nombreuses bases de
loisirs
elles sont à vos portes regardez ce
troisième tournoi international de
frisbee nous fait découvrir un nouveau
sport à la fois souple rapide est absent
de tout stress les français dominent ce
soir à créteil devant les hollandais et
les allemands un début plutôt
encourageant l'île de france est dotée
de nombreuses bases de loisirs comme
celle ci est par ce temps exceptionnel
que nous réserve la météo pour ce
week-end pascal
c'est peut-être l'occasion rêvée de les
redécouvrir aux quatre coins de votre
région vous pourrez choisir le
dépaysement de votre choix
l'escaladent à bois le roi ou les sports
nautiques de saint quentin en yvelines
d'autres sites comme draveil et cergy
pontoise vous propose des activités
ludiques mais si vous avez décidé de
marcher forêt et chemin fléché vous
attendre quoi qu'il en soit vous avez
deux jours pas un de plus pour respirer
à pleins poumons